game pass offers hundreds of games and
with more being added every single month
it can be a lot to know where to begin
but don't worry in this video we're
gonna go over what's new and some gems
worth checking out on the microsoft
service
joining xbox game pass as a day one
release is immortality immortality
focuses on marissa marcel a would-be
star whose fame was short-lived due to
her mysterious disappearance
it's up to you to discover what happened
to marissa marcel by reviewing law's
footage interviews and scenes from three
never released films she starred in by
scrolling through archives of film you
can click on specific items or actors
that will then link you to other clips
or even behind the scenes footage to
explore and meticulously dissect
it does a remarkable job of recreating
the aesthetic of several eras of film
and television which is an added plus
for film buffs or anyone who is a sucker
for those looks of the past which i am
one of them immortality comes from the
mind of sam barlow the writer and
director behind her story and telling
lies two games that are also on game
pass and her story comes with a high
recommendation from me personally
[Music]
midnight fight express is an unrelenting
dance of violence akin to movies like
the raid redemption wrapped up in an
isometric non-stop brawler you play as
babyface a former member of the criminal
underworld who is dragged back in as a
vigilante on a one-night journey to stop
a city-wide criminal takeover combat is
similar to the batman arkham games
hitting you against several enemies at
once requiring you to dodge attacks
happening on all sides and switching
opponents off the cuff with violent
fluidity but it's not all hand-to-hand
combat you'll be cycling through an
array of weapons and guns to clear out
the relentless waves of baddies
as the game progresses your attacks will
grow and become more complex giving use
to a rope that pulls enemies towards you
or a single shot revolver that has a
different variety of bullet types the
game also encourages replayability due
to short and punchy levels with a fun
point ranking system that'll have you
competing against your own score and
creativity in the fight
[Music]
nintendo hasn't said a word about a new
pikmin in years so tinykin is taking the
reins on filling a much needed gap in
the fairly untouched genre of wrangling
together herds of mysterious little
creatures and making them do your
bidding like carrying stuff
you play as milo who lands on earth and
to his perspective everything is massive
thankfully milo comes across tinyken
which are willingly ready for milo's
command to move big stuff create ladders
bridges and more in pikmin-like fashion
tinykins vary in types ranging with
characteristics like being explosive or
conducting electrical currents unlike
pikmin however tinyken features
platforming elements and a larger
emphasis on traversing its environment
so contrary to olimar milo can jump
right on a bar of soap or use bubbles to
float around it's also got the same kind
of tiny person in a massive and familiar
environment like a living or bedroom a
la katamari demasi or toy commander for
the dreamcast pair that up with an
interesting combination of 2d animation
in a big old 3d environment and tinykin
is shaping up to be a really cool
addition to a pikmin like while setting
the stage for its own distinct identity
the mythological adventure immortals
phoenix rising is now on game pass this
was one of the first big legend of zelda
breath of the wild likes that came out
full swing from ubisoft but unlike
breath of the wild had a stronger
emphasis on combat with full-fledged
voice acting and cut scenes making it an
interesting companion for those who
weren't crazy about breath of the wild's
combat and lack of an apparent story
depending on who you ask it's certainly
a more ubisoft approach fit with
waypoints to keep you on track with a
more overtly comedic sometimes fourth
wall breaking tone
but now just two years after its release
it's here to play so maybe you've been
sleeping on it or you're just looking to
scratch that breath of the wild itch or
maybe you've never even played breath of
the wild then now's your chance to try
something in a similar vein with
immortals phoenix rising
[Music]
alright now for something super chill
coffee talk is a slice of life game that
puts you in the shoes of a barista
making drinks for the mystical and
fantastical patrons that come into your
rainy seattle coffee shop and i mean
fantastical i'm talking elves a succubus
and aliens but instead as their barista
you get a lens into the rather humane
even sometimes monotonous lives of these
mystical characters all of which is set
to a cool and calm lo-fi jazzy
soundtrack in between conversations
you'll be making special drinks and
swinging some cool latte art it's kind
of a cool way to detach you the player
from the agency we tend to have in other
games and instead we get to watch
several stories unravel before us all
within the confines of a single setting
in a coffee shop
but you're not entirely removed from it
as you'll often have dialogue choices
that branch conversations in different
directions with different outcomes
as someone who comes from a lineage in
customer service and often took interest
in my patrons lives playing this wasn't
just cozy for the music and the coffee
but the reminder of people's lives and
stories that exist beyond our own
[Music]
but maybe you're not into making coffee
for people maybe you don't even want to
talk to customers maybe you already have
a barista gig and you need another form
of escapism or maybe you're ready to
explore your dreams of being a revered
chef
well then cooking simulator sounds like
the right game for you cooking simulator
sets you loose in realistic kitchens
equipped with utensils stands pots and
pans filled to the brim with ingredients
and everything else you'll need to cook
with including real life physics
using over 120 ingredients you'll have
60 recipes to master which will require
you to utilize knives spatulas ovens and
blenders and of course don't forget the
seasonings the game is so realistic that
you can potentially start a fire but
don't worry what would a kitchen be if
not equipped with a fire extinguisher or
screw it you can just chuck knives
around because why not it's your kitchen
after all who knows maybe you'll take
what you've learned here and make your
mom who you've neglected texting for a
few weeks now something really special
on her birthday to make up for which is
exactly something
um i'm considering doing yeah
and while we're on the topic of
simulation the follow-up to the highly
regarded two-point hospital is here with
two point campus
this time you'll be building your own
university take all that college baggage
of yours the wishful thinking of your
dream educational scenario and put it to
the test like creating your own sports
team who fling cheese or wizardry
classes or a course on vampirism clowns
spy school whatever you want it to be
make the school you wish you could have
attended
or maybe you just want to get carried
away with the plant detail the sidewalk
layout or maybe you just want to make a
monstrosity a symbolic metaphor for the
realities of the college educational
system you can do that too
that said the first installment two
point hospital is also available on game
pass so if education is in your bag and
you're more interested in creating your
dream hospital well that's an option too
[Music]
all right that's august for game pass
but be on the lookout over the next
couple weeks or months there's some
games i'm personally excited to try that
will be coming to the service like
proteus and signalis thankfully we have
plenty to hold us over until then like
cinematic mysteries such as immortality
or violent action romps like midnight
fight express make sure to let me know
if you've tried any of these out and
what you thought of them in the comments
below and remember this is a good time
to just try things you otherwise
wouldn't have considered because why not
alright till next time see you later
[Music]